[Musique]
pour moi un mot ce serait les liens le
SS en un mot c'est le partage
[Musique]
ESS l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est une autre façon de faire
l'économie elle repose sur la loi de
2014 et elle regroupe les associations
les fondations les mutuelles les
coopératives et les entreprises qui ont
fait le choix d'être labellisé
ezus
[Musique]
elle repose aussi sur trois grands
principes une gouvernance intégrante
l'ensemble des parties prenantes un
autre but recherché que le simple
partage des bénéfices et la non
lucrativité ou lucrativité limitée
[Musique]
toutes les activités de la vie
quotidienne par exemple l'emploi
l'insertion le sport la culture les
loisirs mais aussi l'économie circulaire
l'environnement
[Musique]
notre activité s'inscrit pleinement dans
le SS puisqu'on accompagne 8 ouvriers en
parcours d'insertion qui sont chez nous
sur une durée jusqu'à 24 mois maximale
dans un poste d'ouvriers paysagistes et
l'idée c'est qu'à traverser
professionnel pour pouvoir ensuite
intégrer une entreprise dite classique
et ordinaire du monde du paysage
s'inscrit paiement le SOS parce que
c'est une mutuelle et répond à un besoin
de complémentaires santé puisque la
sécurité sociale rembourse une partie de
des soins mais la mutuelle rembourse
l'autre partie la copie la roise
s'inscrit dans l'économie sociale du
fait que ce soit une coopérative sous
statue scope c'est à dire que c'est une
coopérative de travailleurs avec des
travailleurs et des travailleurs qui
font démocratie ensemble dans le travail
ce magasin bio coopératif est soutenu
par une association de clients et de
bénévoles financièrement par des apports
dans la poursuite de l'activité
économique